well i think we have to take it
seriously and i welcome the government's
swift action we think the government
should go further we think they should
be testing as people come into the uk
not just on day two and i'm very
passionate about making sure the
government do more to ensure that people
get sick pay so that people can do the
right thing and isolate when they need
to we've asked for ventilation in places
like schools and the government need to
really be clear on the mask wearing
indoors at venues and we know the prime
minister has undermined his own message
in the past but we need clarity now so
that people can do the right thing but
you are you can automatically test as
soon as you come into the country it's
day naught to date too isn't it well at
the moment what the government is saying
is that when you come into the country
you do a day two test what would you
like to see a day to test yeah and what
we're saying is that people should
actually have a test before they come
into the country okay and that would be
so wherever they are they should be
tested wherever they are that people
should be getting tested before they
come into the united kingdom and what
about planes that are coming in from
south africa at the moment because we
saw what happened in amsterdam people
were taken off the plane and taken to a
place where they were tested that didn't
happen in the uk yeah well we think
again the government of swiftly and
that's right to do so people should be
isolating if they've come from south
africa and therefore they should be
getting those tests and making sure that
we keep track of where this virus is
it's you know it's important that we're
able to do that and that people are able
to do the right thing and that's why i
think it's important that sick pay is
is dealt with now we've had this problem
throughout the pandemic and the
government really do need to take swift
action so that people can do the right
thing we've been living with this virus
for a very long time now and many people
fall through the loopholes when it comes
to getting sick pay so that they can do
the right thing so where are you on
working from home
well again we think the government
should encourage people to work from
home where possible again if we've got
infection that's rising in the uk and we
know that this variant is meant to be
more infectious that it's easier to
catch that actually working from home is
a good thing and you know i've talked
about the future of work as a labour
policy going forward that i hope that
employers can be more flexible with the
way employees work because we've seen
that through the pandemic they can do
and it's actually good for work-life
balance as well so we encourage people
to be able to work from home where
that's a possibility um you say much
more infectious a south african
president uh rambo poses said he's
deeply disappointed by decisions to
impose travel bans on south africa and
that they i have no scientific basis why
is he wrong
well i'm not saying that he's wrong what
we're saying is the government have
acted swiftly and that's right that they
have done so and the world health
organization is looking at this issue as
well and that we need to make sure that
we're doing everything we possibly can
to get um a grip of this virus so that
it doesn't spread we're going into the
winter months now and we know that
that's a real challenging time for our
nhs anyway so if we have high infection
rates and people needing hospital
treatment then that will put increased
pressure on our nhs services so we've
got to do the right thing to try and
limit the flow of the infection rates in
the uk and that's why it's right that
the government take action immediately
the government is also saying that
anybody that comes into contact with
somebody who's got the uh omicron
variant they will have to self-isolate
for 10 days should that be the case with
children as well
yes but i'm not quite sure how the
government are going to identify when
people have got that variant i think
that's still quite yeah
but the pcr test not every single pcr
test is tested on the genomes and what
the virus is so i'm not quite sure
they've got that fully set up yet i'll
be happily corrected by the government
if they come out and explain to us how
that's going to happen but it is
important that we get control of where
the virus is and that people can
self-isolate and follow the medical and
science advice to make sure we control
the virus but children should have to
self-isolate as well if they come into
contact with somebody who's
children can spread the virus as well so
therefore if they are in contact with
someone who's got the virus then yes
anyone who's been in contact with the
virus should self-isolate in schools
isn't it well we've seen chaos in
schools but we've also we've known that
for 18 months now that school children
have had to leave the classroom we've
had classrooms that have been shut for
for covered outbreaks in the past the
government needs to do much more to
ensure that children can have hybrid
homework and some children still don't
have access to wi-fi and to laptops and
to online courses so we've got to make
sure that every child can access their
learning and that catch-up's in place
again the government's own uh
person that they um recruited to do the
independent inquiry into what was needed
for catch-up left the job because the
government refused to do what he
recommended was the case so again the
government really do need to come
forward to help those children to get
their education but we've got to make
sure we control where the virus is as
well so if the if the science advice is
that they need to self-isolate then of
course we should be doing that given
that we're so close to christmas is
there not an argument for closing
schools early i don't think there's an
argument for that now i think the most
important thing is that the children
spread there well you know my children
have to take tests they get them regular
they get them free from the school so we
have a pile of them and they take tests
but those lateral flow tests won't pick
up whether it's pcr whether it's um
ovarian or not will they well they won't
but you'll know whether you've got
covered and if you've got coverage you
should be self-isolating so again we've
got a regular testing system we've asked
that ventilation are in schools as well
and that hasn't come forward and we're
in you know in 18 19 months 20 months
since we knew about this virus so
there's really a need for the government
to make longer-term plans about how we
ensure that children if they have the
virus they can still get their education
how should we decide who's on the red
list if there are european countries
particularly the netherlands that have
got a high number of cases more numbers
than they have in south africa should
they be on the red list as well well
again we should be following the
scientific advice so if the scientific
advice is that we should be putting them
on the red list we should you know we
shouldn't be taking any chances we
should be again if we're testing people
as they come into the country again
we'll know whether the virus is entering
the united kingdom or not and that's why
we think it's important that the
government do that i mean the virus will
circulate globally and again you know
we've seen gordon brown has raised in
the last 24 hours the fact that we
haven't even met our g7 targets to
vaccinate the whole of the world and
there's no point in vaccinating the uk
if the rest of the world has the virus
and it brings back into the uk so we've
got to do more to protect our borders
but protect the whole of the world
against this virus by you know we had a
great opportunity the oxford astrazeneca
vaccine that we're able to develop
through our scientists in the uk we
should be exporting that across the
world making sure that everybody gets
access to that vaccine i understand but
my question is
to in order to protect our borders do we
need to add more countries to that red
list if they have you know how do we
decide who's on the red list and who is
if the science advice is that they need
to go on the red list then we should be
doing that we should be doing everything
we possibly can to control the virus but
the red list is not that be all and end
or like say testing is part of that it's
very important to do that and
vaccinating across the whole of the
globe is very important in that it's not
just one thing that will fix it there's
a number of things that we need to do so
what about people that have organised um
christmas holidays skiing or whatever
and there are cases um in um in europe
at the moment as we saw should they be
thinking again about traveling well
again we've got cases in the united
kingdom so it's not just about where you
are in the world it's about we stop
traveling no what we do is we have
testing in place so we know where the
virus is that we you know when you have
the opportunity
we do if we're testing and that's why
it's so important and again like i say
coming into the united kingdom we should
be testing people before they enter into
the united kingdom as well so that we
can see where the virus is coming
through our borders but we have the
virus here in the uk as well and that's
why it's important that we fix our
sickness so that people can be off sick
when they need to be and they
self-isolate and that our testing regime
follows up again it's a very patchy at
the moment on day two whether people get
that follow-up and whether we're keeping
control of where people are and whether
they're getting that test and whether or
not they've got the virus and they're
doing the right thing by self-isolating
as far as mask wearing is concerned you
don't need to wear a mask in the pub
or in a restaurant well we think that in
hospitality settings that people should
be wearing a mask i got the train here
yesterday evening and it was absolutely
rammed you couldn't even stand up but it
was so full and nobody very few people
were wearing a mask on that train and
again it's so important that people wear
masks when they're in indoors in in the
arenas where they're meeting people and
you know it's mixing in in large numbers
people should be wearing a mask and what
about i did put it to the minister that
you don't actually need to wear it in
the pub
i think people should you know
especially if you're moving around the
pub we people should be wearing a mask
in hospitality settings and you know if
you're in indoor setting there's no
distinction between a pup sitting in the
pub or or sitting in um on a train or
sitting in a hospital you know it's
still a venue that's indoors and we
should be taking the necessary measures
to protect people around us and is it
right and will we continue to have to
have a knee-jerk reaction to every
variant until we know what it's going to
do i think it's right that we respond to
every variant that comes through we know
that that's going to be an issue for us
we do need to however make sure that the
g7 commitments that we made are honored
and that we're able to get that vaccine
across the whole of the globe because we
see that the more the infections
increase the more variants happen and
the more mutations happen with the virus
so we've got to tackle this globally and
not just see it as a uk issue always
great to see you thanks thank you